all right let's jump to this first story
we got this one from timcast.com Twitter
files Executives acknowledged Trump did
not violate terms of service proposed
quote coded incitement to further
violence stipulation it was really
amazing when you read Twitter's Public
Announcement as to why they banned Trump
they say it's all it's all assumptive
language like further incitement and
additional violations will mean and they
say all of that because they never once
say Trump did break the rules but now we
have the internal Communications
themselves
take a look at this some dissenters uh
in Twitter albeit one saying maybe
because I'm from China he says I deeply
understand how censorship can destroy
public conversations
well let's uh let's jump right to it you
have this Annika Nava uh navaroli who
says that they assessed Donald Trump's
tweet and found there is no violation of
our policies at this time now that's
interesting because this woman later
went on to testify for the January 6
committee that she was trying to warn
Twitter that they had to do something
about this take a look at this Twitter
employees on the scaled enforcement team
suggest that Trump's tweet may have
violated Twitter's glorification of
violence policy oh that's really here we
go there's vijayagare less than 90
minutes after Twitter employee to
determine that Trump's tweets were not
in violation of the policy Vegeta sorry
vijigare Twitter's head of legal policy
and Trust asked whether it could in fact
be coded incitement to further violence
they knew and get this
when you when you go through these
messages the amazing thing is you can
see them lying and basically they might
as well be saying guys make up a reason
to ban Trump and get it to me it's got
to make sense it's basically what
they're saying on January 6th Trump said
no violence he tweeted out no violence
were the party of Law and Order on
January 8th he said 75 million American
Patriots who voted for me your voices
will be heard and then he tweeted again
I will not be going to the inauguration
they twist themselves into knots to
claim that because he said American
Patriots he was he was referring to
writers on January 6. because he said I
will not be there he was actually saying
you have the go-ahead to attack because
I won't be there therefore I'll be safe
and then Twitter employees said that
Donald Trump is now viewed like the head
of a terrorist organization no different
than Hitler or the Christchurch shooter
therefore he must be banned how insane
of a concept is that that Donald Trump
regardless of how anyone feels about
Donald Trump and the things that he said
that the idea that Donald Trump is as
bad as Hitler
I I can't I can't take that seriously I
cannot I can't I can't imagine how you
sit with someone and say all right you
said that and now other things that come
out of your mouth I have to make believe
that they're serious too
I I can't even I can't I can't it just
it's so ridiculous
i i people are detached from what Hitler
was really like he was like a war
veteran broken brain I think who is was
it Serge maybe was telling me he lost a
bunch of his friends in the trench he
went out to run a mission when he came
back they were all dead yeah nerve gas
damage a whole bunch of drugs a whole
bunch of uh methamphetamine yeah yeah
there's a big difference between you
know Donald Trump and his Diet Cokes and
McDonald's uh now again I'm not the
biggest fan of of Donald Trump but but
the man was actively calling for for
peace telling people on Twitter like hey
the you know doing the opposite of what
they accuse him of so so for them to
construde American Patriots as some kind
of coded incitement is absolutely
derangement type thinking that is
nonsensical that is as you said insane
these people are absolutely crazy they
lost their marbles they lost the plot
they don't know what's going on here and
and they will think of any reason just
to punish any kind of political speech
that they don't like because it triggers
them and it activates this kind of fight
or flight instincts in them that scares
the crap out of them it's a ball drop by
administration at Twitter because you
you get as an administrator I know this
firsthand doing it at mines you get the
you face with the decision I have to do
what either what I want to happen or
what is right and often what you want is
not what is right so you have to do
what's right and you don't get what you
want out of it but here's my question
because I generally don't understand
like how is there a difference between
between the two you know in my
perspective
I don't want anything from any of these
people if I was a moderate of these
platforms you know you've got uh the
krakensteins are back on Twitter so
thank god well I mean I got to be honest
like the return tweet was actually
really funny did you see it well and I
didn't but I know that they're LOL cows
and I want that sweet sweet milk yeah so
uh the Crescent scenes were huge Trump
reply guys they got banned and I I
believe they got banned for false under
false pretenses and then when they came
back I mean they're like they did the
whole thing where you know I think Don
Jr blocked one of them so he was like
free speech and quotes and I'm like oh
these are the kind of guys there but uh
they they uh posted The Ambiguously Gay
Duo from SNL and it said the Crescent
scene brother return to Twitter to hunt
the ghost of Donald Trump I was like
that's actually really good back in the
day that's a good one back in the when
they were before they got banned I
thought that the The Ambiguously Gay Duo
was it was something that was associated
with them regularly yeah yeah yeah they
made a meme they made a good meme it's
perfect if the world wasn't in such Dire
Straits of starvation and like falling
apart with no electricity and disease
and stuff this would be really funny I
would be loving all this Twitter drama
it's so hilarious because I really love
all these people from all sides you know
it's just enjoyable to watch everybody
go at it if the stakes weren't so hot so
so here's my my view I suppose
they're on the platform they're back
they should have never been taken off
despite the fact that I'm going to argue
with them you know I don't for me
doing what right is is doing right by
the users by by people and the human
rights is what I would want it's strange
to me but I get it I guess people like
it's strange that as you mentioned it
Ian that there would be someone sitting
there saying I know the right thing to
do would be let this person speak but I
hate them so I'm going to remove them
like that that that's crazy to me I'd
have situations where I was like I agree
with these politics but the right thing
to do is put it in the politics bucket
because it's politics even though I want
it to be on the front page and everyone
to believe what I believe so I'd have to
choose to do what was right when you
need to stretch interpretations and make
up things that aren't there to justify
you shutting down a political voice
maybe you're the bad guy maybe that's
when you should kind of reconsider what
you're doing here but more interestingly
Donald Trump hasn't tweeted yet he's
been back on the platform for for many
days and we talked about this before on
the show and I was like hey there's a
big chance he won't actually be using
the platform why isn't he he has an
opportunity here and uh it looks like
Elon Musk is taking his place when it
comes to everyone especially the
corporate media focusing and attacking
him maybe that's one reason why but he's
still not back on the platform he has an
opportunity to reach so many people to
communicate with so many people he's
still not everybody already does though
I mean he anytime he puts up a truth on
Truth social they make it they make
their way to is Roseanne Barr on on uh
social what I'm saying is anyone anytime
that Donald Trump puts a truth up it
makes the truth makes its way over to
Twitter so it's literally advertising
for such well I just think about the
semantics puts a truth up well I know
it's it's crazy it's hard to it's hard
to articulate these things without
sounding he's not talking to Governors
he's not talking to politicians he's not
he's not talking to celebrities he's not
firing back against the corporate media
like he used to be there used to be
interactions that were extremely
entertaining to watch where he was able
to shine with a lot of his character
some people said that it was his
Achilles heel some people said it was
his greatest strength but it was
something that of course galvanized the
conversation there's there's none of
that right now yeah that yeah I see what
you're saying you're right that Elon
might be filling the void I'm looking at
his tweets he had a tweet that had 1.2
million likes uh about go Morocco you
know talking about uh football soccer
um he had my pronouns are prosecute
slash fauci which got 1.1 million likes
um 1.1 million likes he seems to have
taken the role of the the male strong
male that Young Americans or young
humans around Earth are looking for for
inspiration right now it used to be
Donald Trump that's one but the
corporate media and the establishment
need a boogeyman that they go after that
they Galvanize all behind that that make
them responsible for all the wrongs in
the world and that person right now is
Elon Musk yes they're going after him
with anything and everything they can
let me let me let me address the uh you
mentioning about Donald Trump fighting
back and all that stuff I want to pull
up this tweet from 2012. Trump tweeted
the Coca-Cola company is not happy with
me that's okay I'll still keep drinking
that garbage all right all right all
right
you take it back right now Phil back I
take it back that's freaking awesome
that's nice Trump was he was on he was
that that was his platform it was it was
still drinking that garbage
it was it was fire it was yeah take it
back now he just goes on Trump and he's
like the rig Twitter and I'm just like
it's like paragraph at the paragraph of
him complaining about 2020 and it's like
come on Donald Trump does anymore though
and I know I'm gonna piss a lot of
Donald Trump fans off all Donald Trump
does is wine anymore he is just even if
he was like
everyone knows that all these bad things
happened and I was it was you know taken
from me and blah blah blah whatever he
you know whatever his line is even if he
said all that stuff and then said but
from here on out we're gonna focus on
the future and yada yada yada he'd be in
a he'd be much more
he'd attract more voters people are so
tired of listening to him complaining
because even people that were
sympathetic to his his takes before
people like myself and like you know
Luke and and people that was more
critical of them well what I mean was
were sympathetic to the idea that the
the there is a problem in Washington
sympathetic to the idea that there is an
establishment that needs someone pushing
back against him against it people that
were sympathetic to that idea are tired
of poor me they're just over it yeah and
I think that uh I think they're they're
right to be tired of it because I just
if his thing is just poor me then he's
not gonna get anything done he's not
gonna fix anything he's not gonna make
anything better since uh Trump was
reinstated I can pull this tweet up the
actual tweet not an image of it where he
said federal judge throws that stormy
Daniel lawsuit great now I can go after
horse face and her third rate lawyer in
the great state of Texas she will
confirm the letter she signed she knows
nothing about me a total Khan he was the
president
massive cell phone he paid to have sex
with that woman why are you calling her
a horse face you paid for that a lot of
money too dumb man he paid top dollar
it wasn't cheap well you know
he likes horsey women you don't like why
did you purchase that product like
seriously as much as I can be like
you know I've been critical of Trump's I
guess decorum in the past like you know
he can be better people kept saying this
is exactly why they liked him
because he would just he'd just say what
he felt like saying you know he just say
it I mean he was ridiculous and that was
that was the funny thing about him but
that that was also the thing that made
people hate him the most and that was
the thing that that did align the
establishment against him I think saying
what you think can be is a is a valuable
ability but if what you think is evil
horrible dirty things then saying what
you think is going to be bad if it's
good things then saying what you think
is going to be good I think you're right
but I think delivery has a lot to do
with it because there are plenty of
people saying plenty terrible things in
a very gentle way nowadays and it's
getting right by people well let's be
honest Donald Trump was funny he was
humorous and he made us laugh about very
serious issues some people he would he
would push back on when they needed to
be pushed back done but when it came to
uh establishment Powers he laughed at
them and that that has had it has its
own presence that is missing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time